Welcome to the final episode
of this season's Wine Down.
Today we are joined by
the incredible Amanda Seales,
who plays Tiffany.
She'll be helping us break down
tonight's episode,
"Lowkey Lost".
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
A huge part of the episode is
dealing with really
needing to find Tiffany.
Why do you guys feel
it was important for us
to sort of tackle Tiffany's
story line evolving around
post-partum depression?
We wanted to depict this
because, you know,
it's commonplace, and we wanted
to show this struggle.
And just felt like
this was the natural opportunity
to showcase this.
Tiffany's the only mother,
the only married one
out of our group of friends,
and she already started to feel
isolated in a way,
and so
unfortunately this just added
to her burden.
I think Tiff had also
kind of like, solidified herself
as the strong one.
Like, even though she'll allude
to, like, things with Derek.
It's never, like,
been put in her girls' laps.
And, so, I think that also
just reflects the reality of,
"You know, I had a strong mind
but not necessarily
a healthy mind."
So we know how to muscle through
and like,
"That's not gon' break me,
and that's not gon' hurt me."
But it's like are you really
dealing with it?
Or are you just
suppressing sadness?
But that's that character,
right?
AMANDA:
She set this grid up.
Like, my hair is gon' be
together, my--
I even made, like,
a conscious decision
over the course of the season
to, like, let my nails be
less done, so that by the end
she doesn't even
have a manicure,
which for Tiffany, that's like--
You've never seen Tiffany
without this happening.
But, like, I think a lot
of women can relate to
something that might not be
very indicative of, like,
them falling apart.
Because a lot of times it'll be
those little things that
you just know are, like,
"Oh, she's together."
And I think that was
another factor, too,
because, yes, Tiffany's
going through this thing,
but we also wanted it to serve
as a metaphor for
her actual friends
missing out.
Like, her actual friends
aren't noticing that
she's falling apart,
and that is also indicative
of the friendship that
they have with each other.
They're not seeing one another.
You know who was in it, though?
BOTH: Derek.
Derek was in it. (LAUGHS)
Derek was down.
That's what's great,
I think, at the door,
when you guys have
that moment together where
you'd never let Derek see
the other side of that, right?
And I think even not wanting
to answer the door, right?
"How do I face this man who
I typically am together for?
I don't want him to really see
me like this,
'cause what does that mean?
How will he see me now
going forward?"
It still gives me chills
thinking about it
because it was so real,
about a husband and wife
who do need to see each other.
It's scary.
You know why else
it give you chills?
-PRENTICE: Why's that?
-Because I was actin', baby!
(LAUGHTER)
One of the things we discussed
in the room, was from
a very early stand point,
was wanting to tackle
this topic of Tiffany
this year, so...
I would love to talk about how
post-partum depression
is rarely really portrayed
accurately on TV.
Especially with black women.
When it is portrayed it's...
(LAUGHS)
It's wild.
ALL: (LAUGH)
"I can't take this baby."
You know, it's being acted to
the back of the room.
Not to the cameras.
It's not nuanced. We talk about
that a lot in the room.
I remember to a point that
we were talking about
debating what's the most real
version of
what she would be wearing,
how you would find her,
what she would do,
has she eaten?
We got very meticulous
about this,
because we wanted it to feel
very real.
Yeah!
You talked about your nails.
What else did you do to prepare
for Tiffany's post-partum?
I think the hardest thing
was gonna be
just figuring out an authentic
place to tap into that could
get me to the same feeling
of emptiness and confusion
that you would be at
if this was,
you know, your actual reality.
Speaking of pregnancies...
There's a big drop at the end
of this episode,
of Lawrence getting Condola
pregnant.
How do you think Issa feels
about that
and she and Lawrence's
relationship,
possibly, moving forward?
This taints him in
a very real way.
-And I say that--
-Does it?
To me, if I'm interested in
a man and he has a child
with someone else,
I think it robs you of
that moment. And that's my mind.
I feel like they've lost
a milestone.
In the season two finale,
like, when she pictured
getting back with Lawrence,
having a baby together
is the first thing.
So, now--
She don't got the first born.
She doesn't have
the first born.
He's sharing that moment
with someone else.
Someone who he's not with,
and they've just recommitted.
So, there's things to discuss,
like how active he wants to be
in his child's life.
If he's not active,
then he's kind of not shit.
(OVERLAPPING CHATTER)
So, you're like
an antsy girlfriend?
If-- Can Issa and Condola
be friends?
-You were already friends.
-Not after that.
It's gon' be lit.
(LAUGHTER)
Thank you so much for joining us
for Wine Down this season.
We really hope you enjoyed
watching this season
as much as we loved making it.
Cheers.
-Cheers! It's over y'all.
-Cheers to the season cuatro!